Brian obviously you have been in this
business for decades and you are one of
the most successful people in Hollywood
I mean all the way back to a beautiful
mind you have a new movie you have a new
script a new project today where do you
go first who do you shop a movie script
or something okay so tell me how's it
different um movie studios they're all
they all have different personalities of
currently universal is this giant was
amazing sort of winning streak Disney's
always having a winning streak I
probably shouldn't go through every
studio um when it comes to like Netflix
and Amazon okay prime amazon studios it
I I like Netflix a lot we're doing
arrested development on netflix we did
one season we're gonna do another season
I like Netflix a lot I think they're the
way they governed their creativity is
exceptional they believe and if they
love me if they liked the idea and the
foundational elements you're just off to
do what you believe in and they trust it
and it's been working for them would you
take a movie to netflix i would take a
movie to netflix in fact i'm going to do
a movie with that place really but it's
a tort hey i'm gonna do a tour de force
movie that's cinema verte what Eddie
Murphy being as raw as he can be so you
know one of the things about netflix
getting into movies people say well you
they don't open as in as many theaters
you lose that sort of cachet of a big
theater opening do you feel that way um
I matter if movies movies are supposed
to communicate with a lot of people and
if they're not communicating then you
should have chosen a different medium
because there's a substantial investment
in movies you're usually trying to
movies are about a complete experience
in under two hours so you do want it to
connect to people and have an impact on
the culture so I I care about openings I
mean that's what you'll have to prove
that they can do that but i will do it
with them which place is best for the
creatives the people like you people
like me well i like netflix i really
like look I produce Empire
and I did 24 on Fox I like Fox a lot I
think there because there they are a
broadcast network but they're willing to
take more risk than the other networks
okay so I have a question about that be
so kind of risk matters a lot right so I
wonder do you ever wish that Empire was
on something like an HBO where writers
say they have infinite creative freedom
I think HBO is amazing and I've worked
on HBO I think it's perfect where it is
on fox because it's a series it's it's a
should have 20 it should be like 22
episodes and HBO doesn't really do that
so I like that it conforms perfectly to
the fox network sensibility and how many
episodes they produce do the networks
have anything so there's so many
different things to calibrate in terms
of creating some kind of compatible
compatibility do the networks have
anything to worry about if these new
platforms oh yeah they do definitely
they still have because they bore scale
currently so they still have the
advantage but people are now and we talk
about the content is so democratized at
this point in that it's all about the
specific show itself so they have
something to worry about because cable
television and digital platforms are
breaking through with content that
matters really sexy hooks that can be
supported by early interesting
qualitative content so what are apples
plans to get into the content I don't
know I mean I don't know it by the way
I'm interviewing Johnny I've tomorrow
Mimi is ask I mean I think you put me up
to that already yeah but what do you
think about potential plans for them to
get to the content business so that's
something that I wouldn't do well I mean
they I can't say what they should do
because they look through the most the
richest and most successful company in
the world arguably yeah but you're the
exact kind of person they would be
trying to court I think if they get into
it I probably be a good match
oh you would be attracted another well i
mean i'm interested in modern ideas i'm
curious i think that whatever they do
they'll do it in a progressive way I
believe you know a tim cook is a great
leader and a fantastic human being and
johnny is you know a master at an art
form that note that no one else has
mastered on that level so sorry q smart
they're smart people there you've got
the star panel tomorrow with Johnny I've
and JJ Abrams what can we expect well we
can expect that I've done a couple of
pre interviews with them and their
friends of mine we feel really
comfortable together and Johnny said he
wanted to talk about a couple of
subjects he hasn't talked about publicly
and we'll see if he we still do that
he's up for it alright so you're working
on a new show JJ is a real master too i
mean think about it they're both masters
at art forms that are also connecting to
mass popular culture audiences so it's
really they're doing something that no
other people you really other human
beings are doing right now do you think
the quantity of content is diluting the
quality at all ok in fact I don't think
that yeah well I think it's diluted I
think the the amount of content is
diluting impact but I wouldn't want to
say that is having a qualitative effect
because you never know where something
something you're going to see somebody
whether with a unique voice come out of
YouTube there's all YouTube's fantastic
platform um but I do think there's too
much content it's really hard to
differentiate its really really really
hard to differentiate so what happens I
mean what sugar it's sort of it becomes
sort of flat lines I think
um they'll have to find different ways
to get people's attention shows will
have to try to find different ways to
reach people actually I mentioned you
moments ago then I'm GE yes gigantic you
know general electric's a gigantic
public company and they just they're
deciding to differentiate themselves by
doing a television show with us and
National Geographic called breakthrough
which is like 30 for 30 shows meaning
self-contained episodes isolating itself
on problems on the planet and then
solutions that personal individuals do
solve throughout this one-hour program
so it's sort of like innovation reality
TV it is it grant I love that you said
that innovation reality television it
really isn't that is that because we're
shooting these shows relatively
inexpensively but they do because I
think they're high quality they'll do
they will have something they'll support
the quality of General Electric
interesting and for that matter for news
corp in national geo so what's what's
next for you I mean what what are the
things that you want to do that you
haven't done yet you've done almost
everything but the mediums are changing
so quickly um I think I have a scalable
idea that melds a curiosity and
narrative storytelling but I can't
announce it on bluebird but I will
because not this woman um I'm just last
question you know I maker the tech show
I know you're friends with a lot of
people in the tech industry or good
friend Jack Dorsey you know where do you
see Hollywood in Silicon Valley
converging in
most interesting and exciting way well
netflix has begun that but in as you see
that is that amazoness there's other
company but I think they'll be ways that
will be beyond just the sort of binary
platforms they'll be narrative
storytelling in some other alternate
reality I mean when I say alternate
reality I didn't mean VR but it will
possible probably employ the are
augmented dr magic leap which is a
really innovative and interesting way to
experience things but is she magically i
have so i think there are sensorial
experiences that will be melded together
with narrative storytelling that haven't
yet been done what's so great about
magically if we all want to know we
haven't seen it yet to go a lot to get
them to go you guys are gonna get us an
invitation ok ok right cruiser that was
great thank you guys thank you